okay hey treat male hey treat male is
when my crazy crazy hate mail I receive
is read interpretive Li by a
professional voice-over artist /
so-called patriotic music here's a quick
reminder about the full scope of Patriot
mail because thoughts and prayers are
bulletproof Patriot mail written by
Patriots who hate David Pakman because
America and because freedom so I think
that the subject of this Patriot mail is
the bar memo even though they spell it
BA are like the memo from the bar down
the street
rather than William bar ba RR but I'm
pretty sure that's what this hatred mail
is about beyond that I have not been
able to figure out - too much about it
maybe you'll have a better shot in cell
you lost
bar didn't say any of those things you
just put words in his mouth because your
entire world is crumbling you fake news
jew-hating leftist TYT nazi soy boy i
really wonder if David Duke knows that
Jesus was a Jew born to a Jewish father
and a Jewish mother in a primarily
Jewish area Jesus would be horrified by
his attitude you know usually I'm not
called a Jew hater so this is this is
sort of a new one but I do feel pretty
strongly that this has to do with the
bar letter so it's topical I don't know
exactly what point is being made but the
best thing you can do if you don't like
that if you find that type of discourse
unpalatable and you want to fight back
against it but you can use the coupon
code hey tree at 40 to sign up for a
membership on our website when you go to
david pakman.com slash membership select
a membership apply the coupon code hey
tree at 40 you save 40% and hey tree
it's cry because they are impotent in
their ability to hurt the show they send
in the hey
and you sign up for membership which is
why I recommend using the coupon code
hey tree at 40